ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es um nichts Geringeres als
um das Thema internationale Politik wir
werden heute die Frage diskutieren
inwiefern ein Weltstaat politisch
sinnvoll ist und welche Probleme erlösen
kann aber auch welche Probleme damit neu
entstehen das sind die Fragen die wir
uns heute stellen wollen und bevor wir
diese Frage angehen das ist sozusagen
die höchste Frage die man politisch
stellen kann wollen wir uns noch mal
darüber Gedanken machen was eigentlich
das politische
ist ganz grundsätzlich lässt sich sagen
dass das politische darin besteht dass
Individuen das sind vor allem Menschen
vernünftige Wesen man kann natürlich
auch sagen Personen
Außerirdische vernünftige Wesen könnten
auch politisch interagieren das also
vernünftige Individuen gemeinsam sich
zusammentun zusammenfinden und nach
einer bestimmten Ordnung Leben das das
politische ist nicht nur so ein Aggregat
so ein bunter Haufen von Individuen
sondern ist setzt schon voraus dass
dieses zusamm sein nach bestimmten
Regeln erfolgt man kann also ganz
allgemein sagen das zusammen handeln
oder das
Zusammenleben das soll im politischen
nach bestimmten Regeln geordnet werden
und diese Regeln sind natürlich davon
abhängig wer sie vorgeht wer also die
Macht hat wer das Zusammenleben
bestimmen soll im Idealfall bestimmen es
alle gleichermaßen das ist dann die
Demokratie aber wir haben gesehen in
vergangenen Sitzung es gibt verschiedene
Herrschaftsformen z.B auch die Tyrannis
da macht es nur ein Individum auf Kosten
der Gemeinschaft oben rechts mache ich
ein Link zu dieser Sendung hinein stellt
sich also die Frage wer die Entscheidung
hat wer sie haben soll
machtleitimierung und wie sie das
Zusammenleben bestimmen soll das ist
also die grundsätzliche politische Frage
mit der wir es immer zu tun haben und
jetzt können wir diese politischen
Fragen auf verschiedenen Ebenen
diskutieren die kleinste Einheit sagen
manche ist die Familie man kann auch
sagen gewisse Gruppierungen vielleicht
Interessensgemeinschaften
Ortsgemeinschaften Städte Gemeinde
Gemeinden Länder Staaten Nationen und so
weiter es geht immer höher es wird immer
komplexer die
einheitskriterien oder Prinzipien
solcher politischer Systeme sind
Verwandtschaft im fallal der Familie bei
Gruppierungen können es gemeinsame
Interessen sein das kann natürlich auch
gemeinsam sein man ist verwandt und hat
gemeinsame Interessen geographische Nähe
Tradition Kultur und Sprache je nach
Ebene kann ein einheitsfaktor Stärke
oder schwächer ausfallen je nachdem auf
welcher Ebene wir reflektieren auf das
politische wenn ich z.B aus der
Perspektive des Universums die
Menschheit betrachte fallen regionale
Unterschiede gar nicht mehr ins Gewicht
da identifiziere ich mich politisch als
Mensch jetzt stellt sich die Frage wel
die oberste höchste politische Einheit
ist die sich realisieren lässt das ist
jetzt also die Frage was ist das höchste
einheitsprinzip und das ist natürlich
bezogen auf menschliche Lebewesen der
Weltstaat also alle Menschen auf der
Erde da spielt die nationale Politik
keine Rolle mehr oder zumindest nicht
mehr so eine große Rolle wir sind dann
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
Weltbürgerin und Weltbürger Immanuel
Kant hat in seiner Schrift über den
ewigen Frieden diese Idee schon etwas
angedacht
wenn man jetzt natürlich von
Außerirdischen Lebewesen ausgeht annimmt
dass die auch gibt dann könnte man sich
auch vorstellen auf das auf einer noch
höheren Ebene man auch mit diesen noch
eine globale eine
universale kosmologische Gemeinschaft
bilden könnte die nicht mehr nur auf die
Erde beschränkt ist dasselbe gilt auch
dann wenn die Menschen irgendwann nicht
mehr auf der Erde leben sollten sondern
andere Planeten besiedeln voraussetzung
ist dafür dass sich menschliche Person
und Außerirdische Personen natürlich
unterhalten könnte dass sie sich
gegenseitig verstehen über eine gewisse
Kommunikationssprache dass man dadurch
die politischen Systeme und Fragen
diskutieren und lösen kann jetzt möchte
ich auf einen ganz konkreten Ansatz
eingehen internationale Politik zu
betreiben das sind die Vereinten
Nationen hier sieht man das Logo die
Vereinten Nationen oder auch un
die betreiben internationale Politik
aber auch nicht Regierungsorganisation
Ärzte ohne Grenzen das sieht man schon
ohne Grenzen das sind natürlich auch mit
die staatlichen Grenzen gemeint also man
sieht internationale Politik auf
verschiedenen Ebenen die UN bestehen
momentan aus 193 Staaten sehr sehr viele
es gibt nur wenige Ausnahmen die nicht
dazu gehören und sie wurden 1945
natürlich infolge des Zweiten Weltkriegs
und der schrecklichen Verbrechen die
dort geschahen beschlossen Artikel 1
dieser Karter der Vereinten Nationen
besagt vier Punkte die werden gefordert
gleich zu Begin erstens Sicherung des
Weltfriedens zweitens Gleichberechtigung
Selbstbestimmung der Völker soll
gefördert werden drittens internationale
Probleme sollen gelöst werden die
Achtung der Menschenrechte soll
gefördert werden und die UN soll ein
Zentrum für internationale Kooperation
sein man sieht natürlich bereits am
Titel United Nations vereinte Nation das
ist ihr kein Weltstaat das ist hier kein
Einheitsstaat sondern das ist ein
Zusammenschluss
in Art eines Völkerbundes wie schon oft
angedacht wurde also hier sollen
nationale Einheiten immer noch bewahrt
werden nur soll eine Art von Ausgleich
stattfinden man sieht z.B Nummer ein
dadurch dass Blauhelmsoldaten in
Krisenregion eingesetzt werden und zwar
überall auf der Welt natürlich stellt
sich immer wieder auch die Frage der
herrschaftslegitimation wer legitimiert
diesen Einsatz von Blauhelmsoldaten das
ist eine ganz schwierige Frage die auch
die
Abstimmungsmodalitäten der Vereinten
Nationen betrifft und auch die
Vetomächte die natürlich sich immer auch
eigene Rechte nehmen
können was spricht jetzt für die
Gründung eines Weltstaates man kann
natürlich dadurch vielleichtte das
Prinzip der Demokratie auf alle Menschen
auf der Welt ausweiten egal wo Sie sich
befinden
man kann sie demokratisch partizipieren
lassen man kann natürlich auch dadurch
die Gewalten die politischen Gewalten
viel globaler anwenden Exekutive
Legislative und Judikative es gibt ein
Weltgericht ein Weltparlament und eine
Weltpolizei
m das ist natürlich ein Vorteil ein
Nachteil besteht sicherlich darin dass
sowas vielleicht nur illusorisch ist
vielleicht gar nicht realisierbar ist
aufgrund der verschiedenen Mächte
Ungleichgewichte auf der Welt der
verschiedenen Interessen und dagegen
spricht auch unter anderem das dadurch
nationale historisch gewachsen und
kulturelle Eigenheiten eventuell immer
weniger an Bedeutung halten würden
wahrscheinlich wäre die Weltsprache
Englisch und die anderen Sprachen würden
immer mehr aussterben weil man sich
natürlich nur so global verständigen
könnte wir sehen jedoch unabhängig von
einer solchen sehr starken Konzeption
von Weltstaat schon Tendenzen in
Richtung einer solchen globalen
Vernetzung und zwar ist es das Internet
worldwide web wo sich Menschen auf ganz
verschiedene Weise aus ganz
verschiedenen Orden der Welt zusammentun
und auch auf diese Weise bereits
digitale Politik betreiben ich bedanke
mich wieemals für die Aufmerksamkeit bis
zu einer nächsten Folge